our i-team's been looking into alleged
voter fraud across nevada
during today's news conference by the
trump campaign announcing a lawsuit
against clark county
one woman said she went to vote only to
be told that she already had voted
it's a story our i-team's david charns
broke earlier in the week and david is
here with more on that david right so
john we profiled jill stokey during our
six o'clock newscast back on monday
she's legally blind and needs help to
vote but when she went to vote early she
was told she had already voted now
stokey showed us the device she uses to
help her see and she says
she went to go vote in person but was
told her mail-in ballot was sent in
and that her signature matched but
stokey is adamant she did not vote and
believes her ballot was stolen
clark county's joe glorio did not go as
far to say stokey was lying when he
spoke today
but said in their mind she did vote
i personally dealt with ms stoke she
brought her claim to me
we reviewed the ballot and in our
opinion it's her signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide a challenge to that she refused
to do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team also
interviewed her
and they had no issue with the
assistance that we tried to give her
i have nothing else to comment on that
next question so that reporter saying
did you think she is lying he said
no response now in that news conference
earlier announcing that lawsuit
stokey mentioned us here at channel 8
saying that i had told her we had
received emails and calls about voting
inconsistencies
i told stokey when i spoke with her on
monday and the i-team has repeatedly
reported
that voter fraud is extremely rare in
nevada and across the country
and our sources here tell us that there
is no widespread coordinated effort of
voter fraud
that they are aware of we'll have much
more on the story tonight starting
at four o'clock for now i'm david charns
8 news now david thank you very much